hello and welcome back to New rockstars
I'm Jessica Clemons and I'm here to talk
and break down Zach kreger's recent
horror flick Barbarian warning I will be
spoiling this movie like right now so
turn away if you haven't seen it yet
there's no better way to summarize this
movie other than insane it's like Texas
Chainsaw Massacre mates don't breathe
meets The Hills Have Eyes Zach kreger
has been working on getting this movie
to the big screen for just about 10
years now and if you don't know
Cracker's work let me tell you he's one
of five members of Whitest Kids you know
star of Miss March or you might have
seen him on TBS as wrecked either way
this is his big first solo outing as a
writer director and I'd say he did a
phenomenal job what I love most about
kreger when doing this movie is he never
made an outline he just wrote what he
wanted to see happen next which you can
kind of see in the movie so he really
didn't think about it too deeply which
gives us all the more reason to theorize
and use his interviews to decode what we
saw this movie follows Tess Marshall
played by Georgina Campbell and if she
looks familiar that's because it's Amy
from season 4 episode 4 of black mirrors
hang the DJ I love the love episodes of
Black Mirror they're the best she
encounters Keith toshko played by Bill
Skarsgard who only plays creepy and
sketchy characters Pennywise the kid
Roman the list goes on so we're already
led to believe he's up to no good
especially with that sust behavior but I
digress they both accidentally reserve
the same Airbnb later all hell breaks
loose we jump to our second act where
we're introduced to our new character AJ
played by sweet Justin Long who's not
sweet in this movie he owns said Airbnb
and when he arrives oh boy does More
Hell break loose there's a feral-minded
incest baby some dark dark histories and
violent outbursts this movie goes well
Madison says it best at first it was fun
then scary then fun again then spooky
but in a fun way we opened the film to
heavy rain and we see Tess in our car we
hear screams the same screams that play
when we get the title card for the movie
the title card is purple matching the
hidden basement room that room that was
playing the breastfeeding video on a
loop what we learn about this house is
horrific it's revealed that this house
in the 80s was owned by Frank played by
Richard Drake aka the night King though
the quaint suburbs used to be oh so
sweet Frank spent the best better part
of his life stalking kidnapping and
assaulting women on camera in his
makeshift catacomb when asked in an
interview with the writer directors at
kreger who made the catacomb he replied
in my head he built them after 40 years
the house has been turned into an Airbnb
with modern decor and the horrors that
lie underneath have been hidden behind
this one cement wall door the meat cute
between Keith and Tess is great once you
get past the fact that Bill Skarsgard is
not the monster of the movie which
unfortunately doesn't hit until after he
dies at first our red flags were soaring
flying going off about this guy and if
you're wondering why she ignored the red
flags Zach kreger Drew inspiration from
the book gift of fear by Gavin de Becker
Gavin D Becker Gavin D Becker if you
don't know him Gavin is the author and
security consultant mainly for the
government and public figures he
investigated stalkers from Olivia
Newton-John to share he's written a ton
of books on violence prevention how to
be safe and appeared on a ton of TV
shows about it so what I'm just trying
to say is this man knows red flags in an
interview with Trevor Shan craiger said
there was a chapter in the book that was
really primarily directed towards women
and he was incur urging women to pay
attention to these little minor red
flags that men can give off in
day-to-day situations he finished saying
I just wanted to write a scene where I
could load as many of those little tiny
red flags into an interaction as
possible which we see it turns out that
Keith seemingly gives off every bad Vibe
but actually isn't that much of a bad
guy he's just a musician that works for
the lion Tamers a group of artists that
seek out housing I'm assuming to build
communities and he's currently looking
at Brightmoor in Detroit Michigan Tess
is there for an interview to help
research for a new documentary about
jazz in Detroit when Tess is unpacking
in the bedroom Keith leaves his wallet
out on the table and we find out he's
from Springs New York and that he's 510
which is a bold face lie because we all
know Skarsgard is like 6'4 anyways I
digress that night Tess and Keith are
talking about Tess's bad relationships
you're trying to get out of it with her
controlling boyfriend presumably the man
that's non-stop calling her Marcus when
having this Heart to Heart they dive
into why if Tess was inside and Keith
out she wouldn't have let him in clearly
we know that women do take precautions
in most unfamiliar situations more
specifically Keith wouldn't have seen
the danger and walked in without
thinking twice this foreshadowing is
seen later when Tess who was doing
whatever it takes to survive safely and
AJ who is truly blind to all danger
because he is dangerous once they go to
bed Tess's door opens slightly she jumps
out of bed in the background you see the
door of the basement close and maybe a
possible figure which I think could have
been done by the mother the man told us
and we saw she came out at night so she
was just making her normal rounds that
same man later mentioned something along
the lines of the mother isn't the only
one down there and yes Frank is also
down there people are wondering if there
could be more incest children or women
he abducted but we don't know and Gregor
mentions an interview that he's not
interested right now in doing a prequel
so we'd have to see it in a sequel but I
think they would have to come out during
all that commotion so it may just well
be just Frank and the mother down there
now I know this is a bit of a jump but I
want to jump to AJ story because this is
when a lot of information comes up AJ is
played by Justin long and this will be
the second time we see this man's eyes
gouged out in a movie AJ has been
accused of sexually assaulting his
castmate Megan played by Zack creager's
wife AKA aquamarine AKA Sarah Paxton
Sarah also played the narrator of the
breastfeeding video the article that
drops about the assault is from the
Hollywood report who Gregor said it
wouldn't have been authentic if it
wasn't The Hollywood Reporter and the
article was written by Kim Masters an
editor that publishes a ton of articles
for The Hollywood Reporter AJ is a lot
he's been accused of sexual assault he
confirms the sexual assault at the bar
with his old friend Everett who's played
by the writer directors at kreger
originally they reached out to Zac Efron
to play AJ's role because Krieger said I
was thinking I want some kind of
Beefcake kind of himbo later when
everyone rejected the role he came to
terms saying someone disarming and
charismatic as Justin Long seems more
engaging when he's singing Rikki
tikki-tavi yeah I believe he's hella
disarming too also Chad's come in all
different shapes and sizes it just works
well this character goes throughout the
entire movie overly confident
threatening to pull a gun he doesn't
have on an intruder in his basement
yelling at almost everyone he talks to
measuring said basements upsell it
Tessa's fear in discovering the basement
contrasts AJ's excitement and selling it
completely this goes back to the
foreshadowing I mentioned earlier we
find out Tess has been in the basement
for two weeks after AJ yells at Bonnie
the realtor overseeing it I I guess
she's just been drinking that hair milk
bottle I don't know I'm also not a
realtor but including your basement and
your square foot when selling a house
very state to state in GLA FHA HUD
guidelines say finish basements and
unfinished attic areas are not included
in the total gross living area so I
guess including it isn't really an issue
for the dumbass that is AJ either way
while AJ is captured and being forced to
breastfeed while our girl Tess gets out
but not before we see the sweet suburb
flashback of the home like I said
earlier there lived Frank the monster
and the contrast of this messy but sweet
little 80s house was completely changed
once we heard the screaming from the
basement Frank's neighbor Doug tells him
how he's leaving due to the neighborhood
going to [ __ ] bright more in the 1970s
was populated from 26 000 but declined
to nine thousand many of the black and
white long time residents witnessed and
experienced extreme neighborhood
violence including arson shootings and
home invasions so over time in the film
we can see why people are moving out of
the seemingly nice neighborhood the
camera angles in the flashbacks are
intense and amazing craiger pulled from
from the 1983 Austrian film angst where
they used a snori cam snorri camp snory
Camp mounted to you and followed you
around here they used a Steadicam with a
12 millimeter lens and swirled around
Frank to make him feel like an alien
occupying our familiar Suburban Place
unfortunately we see how Frank abducts
his victims one following her home to
pose as Carlos the Detroit Power and
Water Guy and unlocks their bathroom
Windows kidnapping them eventually the
woman he's talking clearly didn't make
it out because we see her dress years
years later after the abduction in the
basement room we also learned later that
Frank has been assaulting women their
offsprings and the situation continued
for God knows how long the mother is an
offspring of Frank and has only known
two lives the abusive violent life with
Frank and the Happy Mother lovingly
smothering her baby in the tapes which
makes sense for her violent tendencies
and Fear To Go near Frank's room the man
play in the mother is actor Matthew
Patrick Davis Zack Creager and Davis did
a lot of research into feral children to
help build the mother and their research
they found that if you are not exposed
to any language by the age of two you're
never going to be verbal is this word
monosyllabic monosyllabic monosyllabic
monosyllabic wait say it again
okay monosyllabic if you don't do it at
the crucial age you will be monosyllabic
so the way she speaks in the movie is
true to the character we see the
horrific tapes of the victims Frank has
taken and they're labeled each horribly
whether it's by their physical features
ethnicity or just occupation he made
sure to note them all which is common
for serial killers to keep some sort of
memory of their victims AJ watches one
of Frank's videos and is shaken to his
core this like paradoxical irony that AJ
and Frank's Mutual abuse and misogyny
hits really hard because AJ thinks of
Frank as a monster and a horrible person
which yeah he is but they both share
that same behavior that they can possess
dominate or just influence women they're
both awful and similar and their own
ways Gregor even mentioned putting AJ to
a moral test in the movie and he
completely failed this really was the
last nail in the coffin to confirm that
this movie is heavily focused on men and
their unconcerning privilege that's
dangerous and goes unnoticed usually by
them while most of the male characters
are killed Tessa survive solely for
playing to the mother's undying nature
to be a mom both characters have been
wounded abandoned and betrayed by the
movie's true antagonist men craiger
wanted the mother to be the most
sympathetic character and she ends the
movie that way booping tests his nose
one last time as her baby oh it was such
a weird sad scene that's my little
breakdown wrap up of Barbarian the movie
was wild and I liked it but it wouldn't
feel right ending my breakdown without
acknowledging how triggering and
horrible the actions are portrayed in
the movie so if you or anyone you know
has been a victim of sexual assault help
is always available you can visit the
rape abuse and incest National Network
website or contact Reigns National
helpline at
1-800-656-hope or that's
1-800-656-4673 you can get 24 7 support
follow me on Instagram and Twitter Lulu
underscore Clemons follow new rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars for more
horror content check out the break room
where we'll be talking about all kinds
of horror content in October thanks for
watching and remember never go into a
creepy basement in an Airbnb folks Geez
Louise
foreign
[Music]